[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام اليس حريا
بالشعب اليمني ان يزلزل الارض الان تحت
اقدام الذين صادروا ثورته
المجيده الم يكن ما يسمى بالحل اليمني
ضحكا على
الذقون ذاب الثلج وبان
المرج الم يخطئ اليمنيون خطا عظيما عندما
تركوا الرئيس المخلوعه يصول ويجول على
هواه للانتقام من الشعب الذي ث
عليه الم يتصرف علي عبد الله صالح في
اليمن كما تصرف بشار الاسد في سوريا اما
انا او نسلم البلد للعصابات
والمجرمين الم يفتح بشار الاسد الحدود
امام كل انواع الارهاب كي ينتقم من
السوريين ويخرب
الثوره الم يسلم علي عبد الله صالح اليمن
للحوثيين بطريقه انتقاميه قذره
الم يصبح صالح كالاسد مجرد مخلب قط في
ايدي ايران ومشروعها الفارسي
المفضوح الم يتفاخر احد الابواق الايرانيه
بان صنعاء العاصمه العربيه الرابعه سقطت
في حضن
الفرس لكن في المقابل لماذا يريد البعض
اجتثاث علي عبد الله صالح واعوانه من
اليمن عن بكره ابيهم اليس من حق الرئيس
السابق ان يتواصل مع كل القوى السياسيه في
اليمن باعتباره قائد حزب عريق لماذا
يلومون صالح ولا يلومون هادي خلفه الضعيف
الذي فشل في تحصين الثوره
وحمايتها ثم لماذا هذا التباكي على سقوط
اليمن في ايدي الحوثيين هل كان اليمن مثلا
في ايد السويسريين ثم سقط في ايد
الايرانيين
واعوانهم لماذا لا يجرب اليمنيون حظهم مع
الحوثييين بعد ان حولهم حكام اليمن
القدامى الى اليمن التعيس قال اليمن
السعيد قال اليس التهديد بالحرب المذهبيه
ضد الحوثيين سيفاقم من اوضاع اليمن ويقطعه
ارا اربا اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
على السيد خالد الانسي الناشط الحقوقي
وعلى السيد يحيى
العابد القيادي في احزاب التحالف الوطني
نبدا نقاش بعد
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل تعتقد ان الرئيس
اليمني المخلوع نسق مع الحوثيين لاجهاض
الثوره اليمنيه 94 فص ا نعم 5.8 لا سيد
خالد الانسي لو بدات معك بهذه النتيجه
يعني هذه النتيجه الان هناك شعور عام اصبح
واضحا للجميع في اليمن وخارج اليمن بان
الثوره عادت الى المربع الاول بفعل
المؤامرات التي حيكت ضدها من النظام
السابق واعوانه الحوثيه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم اولا شكرا على الاستضافه الشيء
الثاني من خلال قناه الجزيره احيي شباب
الثوره الذين هم الان وهذه الايام في
الساحات يناضلون من اجل ثورتهم وفي
مقدمتهم شباب اليسار احيي الشباب الي
معتقلين الان من قبل ميليشيات
المخلوع المسماه الميليشيات الحوثيه وفي
مقدمتهم الثائر يحيى السواري والمعتقلين
السابقين وانادي الشباب اذا هم حق تحرير
معتقلين فليبدا بالمعتقلين الذي لهم اربع
سنوات لكي
يحررهم اشكر
احيي الشهداء اشكر الجرح المعتقلين احيي
القشيبي الذي اثبت انه كان اخر رجال
المحترمين وانه بين ما الفرق بين الجيش
الوطني وجيش
الحاكم
المستبد حي اليمنيين اللي رافضين سيناريو
تمزقهم سيناريو تسليم اليمن لايران اللي
بينفذ الرئيس المخلوع حيهم وفي مقدمتهم
اليمنيين في الجنوب ومناضلين الجنوب
وشهداء الجنوب وحراك
الجنوب احيي شباب الاحزاب واقول لهم
انتبهوا ان تركنوا الى قيادات احزابكم مره
مره اخرى طيب ودافعوا عن ثورتكم الامر
الاخر من باب الايضاح انا اعتقد انه الان
احاور الاخ يحيى والاخ يحيى انا عارف
خطابه هو خطابه مؤامره
صهيونيه
سنا لكن انا من خلال هذا البرنامج حقيقه
انا اخاطب الشعب اليمني
وااطيظ علي عبد الله صالح واستبعد واتوقف
في هذه الحلقه ان اقول المخلوع لمن يتحسس
حتى يعرف الناس بعدين او يسمعوني بدون
تحسس ويعرفوا لماذا نطلق عليها المخلوع ما
هي مشكلتنا الامر الاخر تفضل بس اد نتيجه
التصويت نتيجه التصويت هي تجيب على سؤالك
طد
عم لكن ما الذي اختفه انا مع التصويت نفه
ان احنا ليس في القضيه مشكلتنا مع عبد
الله صالح اني مش قضيه تنسيق وانما علي
عبد الله صالح
هو يعني اساس
اللعبه ليست مجرد
ت علي عبد الله صالح يسلم اليمن لايران
وادات لتسليم اليمن لايران هم الحوثيين
يعني لانه حينكشف ينفضح امام السعوديين
ينفضح امام الخليج ينفضح امام اليمنيين
الذي كثير خدعوا فيه واعتقدوا فيه يعني في
ناس كثير بيعتقدوا ان علي عبد الله صالح
تعاطى مع الحوثيين من الان من بعد 2011
لكي لكي ينتقم لانه حاقد وهذا غير صحيح
علي عبد الله صالح خائن وهنا المشكله وهذه
الكارثه الاكبر يعني وحتى مثلا لو كان
حاقد ايش ذنب اليمنيين علي عبد الله صالح
ينكل بهم ويقتل بهم ويسلمهم لميليشيات
كهنوتيه ايش ذمب اليمنيين يسلمهم لايران
يعني وتصريحات الايرانيين بشكل
واضح يعني احنا نقول يمكن اليمنيين خدعنا
في البدايه وكنا نقول علي عبد الله صالح
في حرب مع الحوثيين عليه واتضحت في
المساله اللعب ان علي عبد الله صالح كان
يسلم اليمن لايران وكان يستخدم الحوثيين
ويكبر الحوثيين وينمي الحوث الحوثيين يعني
الحوثيين كانوا ساعي بريد بالنسبه لعلي
عبد الله ص وغلاف لانه علي عبد الله صالح
كان لديه مشكله ان يظهر امام
الخليج امام العرب يعني بعد ان قدم نفسه
انه مواجه لايران وانه بوابه حمايه كان
كارثه ان يظهر بهذا القناع اذا عدنا الى
البدايات باختصار باختصار بدر الدين
الحوثي كان اختلف هو علي عبد الله صالح
في التسعينات بسبب وقوف بدر الدين الحوثي
مع علي سالم البيض وذهب الى ايران من الذي
اعاده من ايران الى اليمن كان علي عبد
الله صالح وبعد اعاده بدر الدين من ايران
الى اليمن ماذا حدث علي عبد الله صالح رشح
ابن بدر الدين ليكون نائب في البرلمان
وهنا كانت اعلان عن ان هنالك علاقه معينه
بدات يعني وعلي عبد الله صالح يعرف ان بدر
الدين كان في ايران ينسق مع ايران ويعمل
مع مع ايران فبدات علاقه علي عبد الله
صالح وكانت المؤشر الاول ان كلنا خدعنا
قلنا علي عبد الله صالح كان في حاله حرب
مع الحوثيين ودخل في حاله حرب مع الحوث
وهو كان في حقيقه الامر في حاله تنميه
للحوثيين لكي يستخدمهم استخدامات متعدده
يعني جميل جدا جميل جدا تفضل سيدي العزيز
بدايه اقول سلام الله على عفاش الذي
يرددها الشعب اليمني الان ويتذكرون كيف
كانت اليمن قبل الثوره الذي عمل هؤلاء
الذين يتحدثون عن المخلوع المخلوع هو خالد
الانسي الذي لم يعد يتواجد في اليمن
متواجد في فناد تركيا على حساب من راهنوا
به وبا باعوه وباعوا مبادئ التي اعرفها
منذ زمن يا سيدي العزيز تكلمتم عن المخلوع
قلتم مخالب قط قلتم قذره الفاظ اصبحت لم
تعد مجديه
ومسئولا الذي يحييهم وقطع قلبي يا امانه
قطع قلبي خالد الانسي وانا احيي المناضل
يا سيدي العزيز انا اطالب السيد فيصل ان
يعتذر للشعب اليمني من كلمه مخلوع ومن
الفاظ التي قيلت على امتداد اربع سنوات
حتى استمر معك في البرنامج واجيب على كل
اسئلتك مالم فانا اضطر الى الانسحاب انسحب
اتفضل شو يعني عاوزني اعتذر لا من كلمه
مخلوع الاش سدي يا سيدي مش مخلوع الف
مخلوع مخلوع هو المقوع الذي ليس
لهط يقولون
ين اذا انت تقول ان اليمنيين يقول انه
مخلوع علي عبد الله
صالح يا سيدي العزيز اذا كان علي عبد الله
صالح هذا المخلوع الذي لا يريدها الشعب
اليمني هو الذي بيحرك الجيش وهو الذي
بيحرك الحرس الجمهوري وهو بيحرك الامن
المركزي وبيحرك الحوثيين اذا من هو الرئيس
الذي قاموا بثوره هؤلاء عليه قاموا بثوره
ق
وفحشه وبغض وفتاوى وتفكير وتهريب الدواعش
والارهاب الى
خارج طالبك بسحب كلمه مخ حت اتر اخي فيصل
هو اتى ليسجل هذا الموقف لكي يذهب يتجمل
عند علي عبد الله صالح ويقول انا اتيت
وقلت في الجزيره هذا الكلام طيب ماشي خليه
ولا همك تفضل طيب الان نعود الى قلت في
البدايه انه علي عبد الله صالح كان او
يحاول منذ البدايه ان يسلم ايران او يسلم
البلد الى ايران كمل تفضل خذ راحتك اولا
يعني هذا هو المنطقه المشكله ايه حط لي
على الكرسي يا مخرج حط على الكرسي لو سمح
خليني بس دقيقه يا جماعه هذه الكرسي كان
عليها قبل ثواني قبل ثواني يحيى العابد
وانسحب من البرنامج بحجه انه قيل عن
العفاش انه مخلوع وشعب اليمني ثلاث ارباعه
يقول انه مخلوع حرب وانسحب الذي كان على
الكرسي حط على الكرسي اسمه يحيى العابد
يحيى العابد حرب قبل قليل تفضل اخي الكريم
هو واضح انه القصد من الحضور هو تسجيل
تسجيل جماله مع علي عبد الله صالح
والانسحاب ولذلك حتى انا في بدايه الحلقه
قلت لدي استعداد ان لا اصفه بالمخلوع لاني
اريد الحلقه ان تستمر ولا ولا يهرب من من
الحلقه انا اعرف انه يريد ان يهرب من
الحلقه ولذلك قلت انا ساخا طبه علي عبد
الله صالح بدون لفظ المخلوع مع انني من
اكثر اليمنيين من يستخدم هذ سيدي المخلوع
نحن لسنا كلمتنا المخلوع يقولها 20 مليون
يمني ال القضيه الرئيسيه في هذا الموضوع
هذا هو النموذج هؤلاء يهمهم شخص لا يهمهم
وطن هؤلاء يدافعون عن عن عن عن علي عبد
الله صالح ليس عن اليمن لو كان قضيتهم
اليمن ما حتكون مشكله يعني من كان ضيف في
هذا الكرسي كان يقدم نفسه خلال الثوره انه
رئيس لجنه حمايه الشرعيه خليك بس دقيقه
المخ يا ريت تفتح لي التليفونات اي من
عاوز يدخل دخله تفضل انه رئيس لجنه حمايه
الشرعيه حراس الشرعيه الان اذا هي الشرعيه
هل الشرعيه فقط هي علي عبد الله صالح هل
نحن ملكنا لعلي عبد الله صالح هل نحن
حيوانات كي يتملكنا علي عبد الله صالح 33
سنه ثم يورثنا لابنه مشكلتنا مع علي عبد
الله الصالح مش شخصه مشكلتنا مع علي عبد
الله صالح كمان انا خليني يعني اشتغل هون
دور محامي الشيطان بما انه قبل قليل يحيى
العابد هذه الكرسي بتاعه حرب من الاستديو
يحيى العابد اللي هو القيادي في احزاب
التحالف الوطني يحيى العابد حارب او انسحب
من الاستوديو لانه يريد من الشعب اليمني
من 20 مليون يمني ان يسحبوا كلمه المخلوع
التي يصفون بها علي عبد الله سالح عفاش
طيب انا بدي اسالك طيب السؤال المطروح
لماذا تضعون كل اللوم عليه عبد الله صالح
علي عبد الله صالح ترك الحكم منذ زمن بعيد
وهناك رئيس جديد لليمن وهناك قياده جديده
وهناك يعني الاداره كلها جديده لماذا انتم
تلاحقون علي عبد الله صالح حتى الان هو
الذي ينسق مع الحوثيين و ويعطي اليمن
لايران وكذا طيب اذا الرجل مشى مشى الان
خليني اجاوبك تفضل بماذا نحمل علي عبد
الله صالح يعني وبالوثائق انا لن لن اتحدث
فقط بلغه الك كلام انا اريد الناس المجتمع
اليمني ان يسمع ويعرف اللعبه كيف تدور من
البدايه اليمنيون شاهدوا التسريب التي
كانت بثته قناه الجزيره واللي ظهر فيه علي
عبد الله صالح يعطي تعليمات للحوثيين يقول
لهم اعملوا كذا امنعوا الطيران
اعتقلوا حاربوا يعني حاربي ولا ترقدي يعني
جيبوا فلان جيبوا سيد اي سيد يعني حتى
فيها نوع من الاحتقار يعني احتقار لمين
للحوثيين الحوثيين في في ما يتعلق بهم
فظهر الموضوع انه مش فقط علاقه موضوع
انتقام مش موضوع حقد علي عبد الله صالح
ظهر ان الموضوع ابعد من من ذلك انا عندي
هنا مقابله لعلي عبد الله صالح لمن يشكك
في هذه المساله مقابله لعلي عبد الله صالح
مع
قناه العربيه
وهي مفرغه يعني في صحيفه اليمن اليوم هذه
صحيفه علي عبد الله صالح حيبه خالد الانسي
وانتمنى كل مؤتمري كل انسان متعاطف مع علي
عبد الله صالح كل انسان استغله علي عبد
الله صالح بمظلوم النهدين واستغل علي عبد
الله صالح جهله او بساطته ان يسمع هذا
الكلام
جيدا المذيع بيسال علي عبد الله صالح في
في المقابله ويقول له نمر على ملف
الحوثيين في صعده خصوصا المعلومات
المنتشره شوي شوي اقراها شوي شوي مشان
يفهموها نمر على ملف الحوثيين في صعده
خصوصا من المعلومات المنتشره تاريخيا ان
هذه الحركه نمت وترعرعت في عهد علي عبد
الله صالح قبل ان يبدا بمحاربتهم عندما
استغلهم في محاربه السلفيين احنا كنا
نعتقد كده ان علي عبد الله صالح استغل
الحوثيين من اجل محاربه السلفيين من اجل
ابتزاز الاصلاح من اجل شق الشيعه لكن طلع
الامر ابعد من ذلك ماذا يقول علي عبد الله
صالح حرفيا في هذه
المقابله يقول علي عبد الله
صالح طيب كنت انا في جوله في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2006
2006 كان قد حدثت الحرب الاولى والثانيه
والثالثه يعني وتواصلت مع عبد الملك
الحوثي قائد الحوثيين مش ابو راس فقط يعني
وقلت له تعال الى صعده واعتقد انه قد شنت
حرب قبلها او حربين ولا يوجد بيننا وبينكم
مشكله
قال لازال الكلام لعلي عبد الله صالح ان
قال يعني الحوثي تسمع انتخابات زينه وجيده
وفعلا كانت نتائج الفرز في صعد افضل من اي
محافظه في التصويت
كمحافظ تخيل يحصل علي عبد الله صالح في
صعده في 2006 على نسبه 95% من الاصوات اي
حرب لو كان هنالك حرب حقيقيه بين علي عبد
الله صالح والحوثيين هذه مقابله مع مع
قناه العربيه لها ل لها سنوات في من من
2013 ليس من من الان يعني هل معقول شخص
علي عبد الله صالح حارب الحوثي وقتل اخوه
وقتل من اخوانه ثم يتصل له بالتليفون
ويقول له تعال ويقول الحوثي يصوت الحوثيين
له ويخذ فيصل بن شملان اللي هو الشخصيه
الجنوبيه
النظيفه هذا مقابله اخرى ليحيى الشامي كان
محافظ صعده في تلك الايام ماذا يكشف فيها
اكثر من ذلك يكشف فيها ان علي عبد الله
صالح لما نزل الى صعده والتقى بالحوثيين
طيب طيب بس دقيقه دقيقه دقيقه اخ خالد
السيد يحيى السيد يحيى العابد سيعود الينا
مشكورا تفضل استاذ يحيى تفضل تفضل شرف شرف
شرف تفضل استاذ يحيى شرف خذ الوقت كاملا
خذ الوقت كاملا وقل ما تشاء دافع عن موقفك
دافع عن موقفك دافع عن موقفك كما تشاء
ماشي
تفضل اوكي افضل لك الكلام المايك جاهز مع
السيد يحيى سيد يحيى ريح اعصابك شوي
السؤال المطروح قل ما تشاء دافع بالطريقه
التي تريد ماشي
تفضل كيف ترد على كلامه تفضل طبعا نص
كلامه ما عاد سمعتوش وخالد الانسي ك خالد
الانسي نفس الكلام ما هو معهود عليه
بالجرائد وكانه وثائق وكانه في محكمه ولكن
اقول ك خليه خليه له الوقت له الوقت للسيد
يح هذا كلام علي عبد الله صالح هذه مقابله
مع علي عبد الله صالح هذ تاريخ يا س سيدي
العزيز من ادخل الحوثيين الى صنعاء هم
الاخوان المسلمين الذين قادوا ثوره ضد علي
عبد الله صالح وسموها ثوره وهي مؤامره
انقلابيه قادتها اطراف داخليه
وخارجيه من ادخل الحوثيين في 2011 هم الذي
ادخلهم الى ساحات ما سميت ساحات الثوره في
صنعاء في الجامعه وكانوا شباب الصمود هم
الوجه القوي والصوت القوي لساحات التم
التغير ال ساحه التغيير طيب وكانوا هم
حلفائهم في 2011 في 2014 اختلفوا على
الجانب السياسي ماذا هل ستشارك في الحكومه
او لم تشارك وتورطوا احزاب المشترك
وحلفائهم والاخوان المسلمين وهادي ومن
يسوقهم جمال بن عمر وغيره على اساس هل
الحوثيين جزء من التركه الذي اعتقدوا انهم
ورثوها او لا جميل جميل فالذي حدث يا سيدي
العزيز عندما وجد انصار الله انه ليس لهم
كانت في السلطه مسكوا على مواجع الشعب
الجرعه كانت التوريط واستطاعوا بوج شو
يعني الجرعه الجرعه التي اعلنتها الحكومه
برفعه زياده النفط فكان الصوت القويه التي
لامست الشعب واثرت عليه فخرجوا كلهم الى
ساحه الاعتصام في المطار وغيرها تقولون
حلف مع علي عبد الله صالح مع الحوثيين يا
سيدي العزيز وضحت من هو ادخلهم الى صنعاء
النقطه الثانيه سيدي العزيز 70% من
المؤتمريين المحسوبين على حزب علي عبد
الله صالح الذي قلته في تقريركم انه الحزب
القوي ولماذا يريدون اجتثاثه 70% الم تم
اعتزالهم وفي بيوتهم انا احد الذي من ثلاث
سنوات تم اقالته وموجود في منزلي اذا وصل
انصار الله الى وسط صنعاء واراد ني ان
اساند بسلاحي حتى ابعد هذا الحكم الظالم
للشعب اليمني ستفعل كنت اعملها لماذا لا
لماذا لماذا لانه شعور بالظلم لانه وجدنا
من ارادوا خرجوا على اساس انهم يحررنا من
اسمو علي عبد الله صالح ونظامه وثورته
كانوا هم
القتله المحامي خالد الانسي ماذا عملتم يا
ثوار يا الذي تناشد الان وتقولون وتقولون
ماذا عملتم من اجل شهداء جمعه
الكرامه هل قلت لهؤلاء الشهداء او زرت
اسرهم او تابعت قضيتهم اين هم لانك داري
من هو القاتل القاتل اللي هو الطريد علي
محسن الذي دخلوا انصار الله وادبه هذا
الثائر وادبه حميد الاحمر وادب كل على
اليمن وارادوا ان يحرروا البلاد هذه من
قبح المؤامره الي قادتها مجموعه الدول
الخارجيه والمبادرات وما الى ذلك الان لا
يوجد مخرج واحد ال اليمن الا ان نكون
متفقين ان نجعل من الحصانه طب بس ماذا
تفعل بالحوثيين الحوثيين جزء من لم ياتوا
من القمر ولم ياتوا من فارس ولم ياتوا من
روما هم مواطنين جزء اصيل من اليمن من
اليمن ولا احد يستطيع ينكر لو لم يكن جزء
اصيل لما وصلوا الى وسط صن جميل جميل ا
كيف ترد كيف ترد رد عليه هذا الكلام سؤال
وج سؤال وج اولا الحوثيين عندما دخلوا الى
ساحه الثوره معناها ان احنا خليناهم
يتركوا البنادق وينزلوا يتظاهروا سلميا
وفرق بينك البنا فرق بين البنادق ما دخلكم
بالبنا انا عارف ان الاخ يحيى جا هنا لكي
يقاطع ويصيح عشان بعدين يرجع ويحض بقاروره
عطر من يحيى وكرفته من عمار وشين من صالح
انت بتح في تركيا بامات ودولارات صحاب
الدولمن الان اقول لهم احجزوا لي العطر
والكوي لا ريت ماخص الموضوع رد عليه
سياسيا
رد عليه سياسيا هي فرق في قضيه ان الحوثي
ياتي الى ساحات الثوره ويتظاهر سلميا وفرق
بان ياتي به علي عبد الله صالح ويدخله
باسه الذي ادخله الاخوان الاخوان هذه هذه
اكذوبه علي عبد الله صالح في ذات المقابله
وانا بقراها واتمنى الكاميرا تركز عليها
قال هنالك قياده عسكريه يمنيه تقول انه
كلما كان يقترب الجيش من الحس من الحسب
يتصل علي عبد الله صالح لوقف الحرب شوفوا
اجابه علي عبد الله صالح ايش يقول كنت
اشفق عليهم لانهم محاصرون كلما ضاق عليهم
الخناق اقول لهم اوقف الحرب علي عبد الله
صالح كان يوقف الحرب بتليفون يعني لما لما
الحوثيين يخنق
ذا لماذا
لماذا السؤال يعني يعني في الاخير في
الاخير حقيقه خلنا
بالموضوع في الاخير هذا علي يعني الاخوان
علي عبد الله صالح انا من الناس الذي
يطالب بتحقيق كيف ادخل الاخوان
الحوثيين وعلي عبد الله صالح هو من اعطاهم
المعسكرات لم يسيطر الحوثيين على المدينه
الا فيها معسكرات من الحرس الجمهوري او
معسكرات من القوات الخاصه التي يقودها
اقارب علي عبد الله صالح وابناءه اما اما
المناطق المناطق التي لا يسيطر عليها علي
عبد الله لم يستطع الحوثيين ان ان يدخلوها
هل تتصور ان السلفيين وهم جماعات دينيه لا
تؤمن حتى بحمله سلاح قاوموا الحوثيين اربع
اشهر حتى ضغط عليهم علي عبد الله صالح
لانهم من الموالي له ان يخرجوا من من دماج
ويسلم
الحوثين السلفيين موالين لعلي عبد الله
صالح الحوثييين موالين علي عبد الله صالح
الدواعش موالين لعلي عبد الله صالح
القاعده موالين علي عبد الله صالح هذا
الرجل عظيم هذا مفروض ان احنا نقبل جبينه
مادام بهذه القوه ولحد الان وبعد ما سلم
السلطه يا سيدي العزيز المقابله الي يقول
عنها خليه كمل تفضل تفضل اكمل اكمل
المقابله هذه حقيقيه لا انكرها حدثت ولكن
على اساس انه لا يدس السم في العسل علي
عبد الله صالح في حواره هذا حدد باللفظ
الواحد عندما كنت الاحظ ان الجيش الذي كان
يقوده علي محسن في حربه الذي كان يستلم
اموال على اساس محاربه الروافض ها عندما
ارى الجيش انه محاصر كنت اتصل على اساس
انه اقنع الطرف لانه كان رجل دوله مش زي
ما الان
مايع فيوقفها على اساس انه يفك الحصار عن
الجيش وحتى لا يقتلوا على اساس تدخل هدنه
كان هناك اطراف اخوانيه الحوثييين عندما
هدموا وبيت حميد الاحمر وعلي محسن
واستهدفوا هذا الاشخاص هم يعرفون من هو
عدوهم من ذ الحروب السته اليوم عدوهم الذي
قال انه النظام الاساسي وهو رجل النظام
الاول الرجل الذي انهارت المؤسسات
العسكريه والجيش والدوله عندما اعلن
انضمامه الى ما سمي بالثوار لتحقيق اجندته
ونفس الاجنده الذي جعلته الان لاجئ في
السعوديه فماذا يقولون الان علي عبد الله
صالح اذا كان الحرس الجمهوري والمناطق
وتشتي تقول انهم كلهم علي عبد الله صالح
فعل وانت مقتنع ان ثورتك هذا الذي تمت في
2011 هي خرجت البلد الشب اليمني ثوره
الشعب اليمني انا من الشعب اليمني واقول
مش
ثوره اذا كانت ازمه سياسيه
ومؤامرات يا سيدي العزيز اذا كانت ثوره
ومطالب شعبيه وحدتنا مهدده وهم يريدون
الوحده هؤلاء الشباب الذي نزلوا وهم اطهار
في بدايتها وحدتنا مهدده اذا كان من اجل
الامن والاستقرار الامن والاستقرار لم يعد
موجود بسبب ثورتهم اذا كانوا يريدون
محاربه الفساد الفساد الان موجود وجلال
هادي وابوه وينصحون اموال المساعدات
وميزانيه الدوله والدول المانحه وياكلوها
الى جبهم وهؤلاء الثوار ساكتين هؤلاء
الثوار اتحداهم الان اتحداهم الان انهم
يطالبوا بمطالب شعبيه حقيقيه ان نتجه
جميعا الى صندوق الانتخابات وتكون هناك
عبر مجلس النواب الذي قدمت استقاله هذه
اليه ان يتم تشكيل موجب الدستور يعود
الدستور لانه مرجعيه الشعب اليمني الماده
115 الاستاذ خالد قانوني و16 تقول هيئه
رئاسه مجلس النواب هي التي تتولى السلطه
وتحدد فتره انتقاليه انتخابات رئاسيه يطلع
رئيس جني ويحكم اليمن عب قناعه الشعب دون
شغل الميليشيات والخراب جميل جدا كيف ترد
عليها الرجل الرجل يقول بس لا لا لا دقيقه
دقيقه انت تقول انت تقول الان انه علي عبد
الله صالح النظام القديم اه ماشي بالتحالف
مع الحوثييين اعادوا الثوره الى المربع
الا المربع الاول طيب انت الان يقول لك
الرجل اذا كانت ثوره فعلا فلتخرج ثوره
الان وتطالب بالحقوق والمطالب اللي طالبت
فيها اتحداكم ا طيب الان انتم تقولون
وعدوها للمربع الاول طيب يا سيدي قل للشعب
اليمني اخرج الان وزلزل الارض تحت اقدام
الذين سرقوا ثورتك صادروا ثورتك هذا الرجل
يتحدث كيف ت اولا عبد الرب
هو نائب علي عبد الله صالح 17 سنه وهو في
نفس الحز نفس الحز وعلي عب علي عبد الله
صالح كان يقول هو الايادي الامينه التي
سلمها السلطه فاذا كان سيء فهو اختيار علي
عبد الله صالح لم يكن اختيار الثوره
مطلقا لماذا قبلت به الثوره الثوره لم
تقبل هو فرض فرضته دول المبادره فرضه من
يريد منار من اراد ان
يضحك عليكم اذا الح
ليس الامر الامر الثاني علي محسن وانا مش
مدافع عن محسن علي محسن كان قائد عند علي
عبد الله صالح مادام علي محسن هذا كان
شرير لماذا علي عبد الله صالح لم يحاسب
علي محسن يعني كان علي عبد الله صالح رئيس
الجمهوريه الامر الاخر احنا لما تعاملنا
مع الحوثيين ما كناش نعرف ان هم عملاء مع
ايران لكن علي عبد الله صالح وهو موجود
هنا في المقابله يقول لك انه هو عارف انه
مع عملاء مع ايران كيف ينسك مع عملاء
ايران ويخذل الخليج ويخذل اليمنيين ويسلم
اليمن افترض انه تنس يعني هذا فرق بين
ثائر في الساحه ما يعرفش المعلومات وبين
رئيس عنده اجهزه استخبارات وعارف ان
الحوثيين وكان يتهمهم وكان يحاكم خلايا
وفي
الاخير يروح يسلم اليمن لايران حتى لو كان
من باب الحقد حقد على من على الشعب اليمني
على شعب تحملك 33 سنه يعني لانه ما لانه
قال لك اترك السلطه يعني خلينا ن خليك شوي
خليك شوي يا استاذ العزيز نعيش حر احرار
ماشي مثل ما سالته بدي اسالك طيب البعض
يقول بس خليني بس خليني اسالك مثل ما
سالته مثل ما سالته البعض يقول بصراحه انه
العمليه واضحه تماما هذا الرئيس مثله مثل
بقيه الطواغيت العرب الطواغيت العرب اللي
هو يا اخي الرئيس اليمني الرئيس علي عبد
الله صالح المخلوع اللي بسموه اليمنيين
المخلوع المخلوع اليمنيين بسموه يا سيدي
مخلوعين
ماشي ماشي ماشي ماشي ماشي اه علي عبد الله
صالح ماشي علي عبد الله صالح مثله مثل
بقيه الكذا كان شعار هؤلاء اما انا او
نسلم البلد للشياطين فعلها بشار الاسد
بسوريا اما انا او افتح البلد لكل انواع
الارهاب كي تخرب الثوره وكي يكفر السوريين
بالثوره ماشي علي عبد الله صالح من اجل
الانتقام من اليمنيين ومن الثوره اليمنيه
سلمها لالد اعدائه لناس حارب معهم ست حروب
هذا مش سؤالي هذا سؤال يمنيين جاوبهم تفضل
اوضح اولا خالد يتباكى من اول على اساس
انه خدعنا وزد علينا وسار ايران يعني ان
تكون عميل لايران مشكله لكن ان تكون عميل
لامريكا انت حبوب ولطيف ان تكون عميل
للسعوديه حنين وفي ريالات سعوديه اذا انت
كنت عميل لاي دوله كانت معناها انك لطيف
ايران هذه تفج فاذا كانت عندهم عقد مذهبيه
او طبقيه او مناطق او ه هويه فهذه مشكلته
جميل فيما يخص علي عبد الله صالح يا سيدي
العزيز من قام بالثوره والربيع والربيع
العربي هذا هو معروف والقضيه معروفه
واتضحت للان واتضحت للان واتضحت للان انها
لم تكن ثورات وانما كانت مؤامرات انقلابيه
في كل الدول بشار الاسد رضوان الله عليه
دافع عن وطنه رضوان الله عليه ورضي الله
عني ورضي الله عنه وكل واحد يحب ربه الله
يرضى عليه فلا تنظر اليها انها هذه
حرام فاقول لك ما دام كل العالم وكل ارهاب
العالم ودواعش العالم هجمت على سوريا من
حق ان يدافع عن وطنه اذا كان لك خلاف مع
النظام السوري فهذا شانك لكن ارى ارى انه
جت في اطار منظومه واجنده ربيع عربي ستسقط
سوريا وتدمرها وتبيد وستسقط اليمن وتدمر
وكلها فاذا كان هذا الربيع يريد ان يبيد
هذه الشعوب التي هي من الشعوب العربيه
الاصيله والمقاومه والرافضه لكل ذل وخنوع
اذا كان هذا مصيرها فسيل عن ابوها ثورات
جميل جدا كمل على اليمن كمل على اليمن
اليمن اليمن علي عبد الله صالح سلمها نعم
على ما قال هو نائبه لكن اتضح ان عبد ربو
منصور هذه جزء من الاجنده هذه وكما قلت لك
هو امين عام مساعد امين عام سابق
وتم فصله من المؤتمر الشعبي العام من
منصبه كامين عام اذا كان في عهد حكمه 70%
من المؤتمرين روحوا على بيوتهم 70% 70% من
الموظفين اللي في عهد هادي في عهد هادي
الذي هو امين والذي زعلوه ليش قالو هذ من
الحزب طبعا هذه معلومات يثبتها تحداها
يثبتها كلام غير صحيح هو عينه علي عبد
الله صالح لانه كان يدافع عنه بطريقه غير
قانونيه وبعد ين القانونيه ه الجراد رجعين
خلينا ن جابر سوا سمعت يا سيدي العزيز
فعندما فشخص زي ما هذا الارض الان الوطن
اليمني يعاني اقتصاد كل شهر يروح وزير
ماليه وزير خارجيه على اساس لدوله خليجيه
تدعمنا في مرتبات توصل لليمن يشيل لها ابن
وجلال ويطرحها في صناديق ويروح على اساس
انفصال الجنوب ودعم ميليشيات نفس اللجان
الشعبيه الذي بيشكوا منها الحوثيين
موجودين في صنعاء هناك لجان شعبيه من ابين
بتسيطر على المحافظات الجنوبيه وبتسقط
المعسكرات لقد عملوا اكبر فضيحه في تاريخ
الشعوب فماذا تنتظر من الشعب اليمني هل
سيوافق على ثوره تريد تقول انه انه انت
تتحداهم الان انه الشعب اليمني لن يثور
معهم لاعاده الثوره الى الى نصابها كما
الشعب اليمني يريد سلام ويريد صندوق
انتخابات لتحديد خياراته وينتقل من ظل
دوله الازمه الى ظل الدوله جميل جدا انا
اسالك الرجل قال قبل قليل لماذا عن لديكم
هذه العقده الكبيره من الحوثيين وهذه
العقده المذهبيه سؤال يطرحه الكثيرون الان
طيب وما العيب ان ينسق علي عبد الله صالح
مع الحوثيين فلينس مع الحوثيين اولا علي
عبد الله صالح صاحب جماهيريه كبيره في
اليمن حتى الان ولديه حزب يضرب جذوره
عميقا في الارض اليمنيه صح ولا لاقه وهذه
حقيقه من حقه ان ينسق مع الجميع كحزب قوي
اه طيب ليش الحوثيين ليش لماذا الحوثيين
طيب لماذا لا يجرب الحوثيون حظهم يعني هل
اليمن كانوا بيحكمو سويسريين وبعدين اجوا
الحوثيين واخذوهم الايرانيين خليه يجرب
يعني هل كان اليمن سعيدا كي يصبح تعيسا في
عهد الحوثيين ام انه حكامه القدامى ودو ب
60 داهيه لليمن فليجرب الحوثيون حظهم فل
تجرب ايران حظها بعدين بدي اسالك لماذا
هذا العداء الكبير لايران وايران وايران
وكانه يعني الدول العربيه يعني كثير بتحب
اليمن وبتحب سوريا وبتحب العراق يا حبيبي
اكبر المتامرين على بلداننا هم عرب عربان
فليش زعلانين من ايران يعني خلي اجرب
ايران يا سيدي بلكي تطلع احسن منه لهال
العربان على كل حال انا ضد كل من يلعب
بامن اليمن ايران ولا غير ايران انا مع
اليمن مش مع شخص انا مش جاي ادافع عن عن
عبد الله صالح ولا علي محسن ولا الاصلاح
ولا الاحمر تص في هؤلاء الناس كلهم انا مع
بلدي
يعني البد العابد هو مدافع عن علي عبد
الله صالح وعن بشار وعن السيسي وعن
القذافي عن كل الدكتاتوريات والطغاه وهذه
هي المشكله مش عن
الاوطان اجاوبك على سؤالك بس بدون ما ترج
اجاوبك اجاوبك اخي فيصل اخي فيصل اجاوبك
على سؤالك بس اولا خليني اجاوب على صناعه
الدواعش على صناعه القاعده هذه مساله لا
يجوز ان تفوت في المقابله مع علي عبد الله
صالح يسالوه عن لقاء كان علي عبد الله
طالح يتحدث بقا يعني هو صنع الحوثيين وهو
صنع القاعده كمان خليني خليني اقرا من
كلام علي عبد الله صالح انا ما جبت شي من
عندي صحفته وكلامه وهو بيقول لك مقابله مع
علي عبد الله صالح هو بيتحدث بلقاء معه مع
بوش قال قال انه قال لبوش نزل الجريده
مشان يشوفك انا ماليش دخل بهذا الموضوع
قلت له بوش تربيتكم انتم او عزم الينا يا
امريكان ايام الحرب في افغانستان لمحاربه
الاتحاد السوفيتي وانتم الذي فرضتم علينا
تجنيدهم هؤلاء الاسلاميين ذهبوا من اليمن
ومن غير اليمن وزودت موهم بالصواريخ الذي
كان يصنع الدواعش لحساب امريكا هو علي عبد
الله صالح فالعميل فالعميل هو الذي كان
يذهب باليمنيين ليموتوا في افغانستان
لحساب لامريكا كيف الان يقولوا دواعش
وارهاب علي عبد الله صالح يعترف انه كان
يجند ناس تذهب الى افغانستان لتموت لحساب
امريكا لم اكن انا رئيس الجمهوريه الذي
قمت بذلك الامر الاخر الح ليس لدينا ليس
لدينا مشكله ليس لدينا مشكله ليس لدينا
مشكله مع مع الحوثيين وحتى وان يتولوا حكم
اليمن مشكلتنا مع الحوثي في محاوله فرض
نفسه بالقوه وبالعنف مشكلتنا مع الحوثي
انه انه انه انه يق
يقتل اليمنيين
و صور نفسه انه سائر نريده ث وصور نفسه
انه ثائر وانه في حاله حرب وان علي عبد
الله صالح وهنا ها هي مقابله مع احد قاده
الاحزاب يقول ان بدر الدين كان مستعد
لتسليم نفسه للشيخ مجاهد لكن علي صالح
حسين بدر الدين الذي هو اخو عبد الملك
الحوثي الذي يفترض ان من قتله علي عبد
الله صالح كان مستعد نفسه وعلي عبد الله
صالح من رفض ان ان يسلم نفسه بمعنى علي
عبد الله صالح كان يستخدم الحوثيه لتدمير
اليمن لنهب الخزينه العامه تخيل عندما 60
ال اسره 60 الف اسره
قاتلت يعني فقدت ابنائها 60 الف شخص في
الحروب هذه ثم ياتي علي عبد الله صالح
يتحالف مع هؤلاء الذي يقول انهم عملاء
يران والذي يقول انهم انهم انهم انهم
روافض انا اتي من من
كلامه هذا الفرق هذا هو الفرق يعني يعني
يستخدم معاناه الناس لكي يستمر في الحكم
يعني استخدم الحوثي لكي ينهب الخزينه
العامه المال العام استخدم الحوثي لكي
يبتز السعوديه يتحدث من العماله وه تصور
علي عبد الله صالح كرئيس جمهوريه كان
يستلم 40 مليون ريال شهريا من السعوديه
وهو رئيس
جمهوريه وهذه صحيفه ياسر العواضي واحد من
الموالين ل الله صالح ومن اكبر الاقطاب
انا انت وجدت انا بنعطي الدليل مش بكلم
وفي الاخير وفي الاخير ياخذ اموال
السعوديه ويذهب يسلم اليمن لايران لكي
ينتقم من اليمنيين انهم قالوا
له ارحل يقتل اليمنيين لانهم قالوا له
ارحل المطلوب مننا ما المطلوب مننا
الحوثيين الحوثيين حصلوا على فرص جاءت
الثوره والثوره لم تق لهم لا تدخلوا الى
ساحه الثوره في الاخير انهم دخلوا الى
ساحه الثوره لكي يجوها من الداخل والاخ
العاد ل مقابلات
يتحدث من الداخل انهم دقيقه بس دقيقه كيف
ترد على هذ بس دقيقه كيف ترد بدي اياك ترد
على هذه النقطه مهمه انه علي عبد الله
صالح من خلال التسريبات الاخيره الصوتيه
كان يعمل منذ البدايه مع الحوثييين لاجهاض
الثوره ثوره مضاده ونجحوا فيها لا انا قبل
ما ارجع على سؤالك هذا اقوللك الذي
بيقولوا انه بيستلم 40 مليون والذي فسد
وين انهب الخزينه وطلع وطلع في الثلاث
سنوات هول الثوار الذي قادوا ثوره ما هي
كل الحقائق امام الناس والكل يعرفوها ان
هذه بيسرق هو ابنها الدوله ماذا عملوا هم
حكموا اليمن ثلاث سنوات بعد تسليم علي عبد
الله صالح السلطه وقادوا بلد الذي هم
الثوار ومخرجات الثوار ماذا حقق ماذا
حققوا هل وجدوا على علي عبد الله صالح
دليل واحد يثبت صحه كلامهم يخرجوا الم
اموال المنهوبه والوثائق يديلي وثيقه من
بنك ولا من بنك سويسري مش يديلي جرائد
مهلهله عندما يقول قالت صحيفه انه بيستلم
يا سيدي اذا كانت هذه الصحف كلها بتقول
هذا الكلام واصبحت وثائق بجيب الصحف الذي
يشتي والذي تنش نعم جميل جميل حسين بدر
الدين الحوثي عندما يقول ان علي عبد الله
صالح هو الذي كان يسلم وما يسلم وما الى
ذلك ما حدث انه حسين بدر الدين الحوثي
عندما تم القبض عليه رحمه الله الشهيد
حسين بدر الدين الحوثي عندما شهيد وقلتها
وقلتها شهيد وشباب وشباب جمعه الكرامه
شهداء والذي في جامع النهدين
كه ما كنت تقول شباب
جمعه مش المعيار يا سيدي العزيز اقول لك
اذا كان حسين بدري الدين الحوثي تم القبض
عليه وتم الا استلامه وتم ابلاغ علي عبد
الله صالح وهو في عرس احد ابناء اخوته في
سنحا انه تم القبض عليه بلغ الناس وهذه
معلومه واقولها الان ومسؤول عليها وقال
لهم الحمدلله تم القبط على حسين بدر الدين
الحوثي وان شاء الله يجي وتكون الامور
طيبه وته
البلد لظه
لظه خل كمل خليه كمل تفضل تفضل اكمل
اكمل لانك حقي ما تعرف
تتكلم جاي تقول هذا
الكلام
اقا يا سيدي العزيز بعدها بنص ساعه تم
ابلاغ ان جواس قام بقتل جميل جدا بس مشان
ما ناخذ تفاصيل كثيره انا اسالك قلك طيب
انت تقول لماذا لديكم هذه العقده من
الحوثيين ولديكم هذه العقده من ايران بس
دقيقه بس دقيقه بس دقيقه والتسريبات بس
خليني اسالك هذا السؤال مشان ما يروح طيب
محمد صادق الحسيني اهم المتحدثين باسم
ايران يقول لك صنعاء يحتفل احتفال رهيب
يقول لك صنعاء هي العاصمه الرابعه التي
سقطت في حضننا في حضن ايران عن طريق
الحوثيين وكل اللي ما يحدث في في اليمن
الان عن طريق الحوثيين طيب انتم الحوث هل
نظرتم الى ما يحدث في لبنان هل نظرتم بدي
اسالك بدي بس خليني بس خليني اسالك انا
اقول بعض الناس يسالون يقول يا اخي نحن لا
مانع لدينا فلتاتي ايران وتحكم و فلتا اخذ
ايران حصتها من بلادنا تيجي تحكمنا بس
لننظر الى سجل ايران في المنطقه انظر الى
العراق الذي دخلته ايران ذهب في 60 الف
داهيه انظر الى سوريا التي دخلتها ايران
ذهبت في 60 ال داهيه انظر الى لبنان اين
هو الان الدور عليكم في اليمن طيب انت
تقول ليش هال المشكله مع ايران ايران سجله
في المنطقه انظر لم تدخل ايران منطقه الا
وخربتها ليست مشكلتي مع ايران مشكلتنا
القوى السياسيه الموجوده في اليمن الذي لم
تعمل من اجل وطن عملت من اجل الارتهان من
اجل تركيا من اجل ايران من اجل امريكا من
اجل كل الدول الذي اساءت لليمن ولكل
الشعوب العربيه وما يخص التسريبات اذا
كانت التسريبات هذه عامله مشكله وقالك يا
سيدي العزيز في 2011 في قناه الجزيره حميد
الاحمر بيقول عندما تم عزل المحافظ الذي
تم تعيينه في عهد علي عبد الله صالح وعين
المحافظ فارس قال فارس مناع قال عادت الى
حضن صنعاء وصعدا اصبحت امنه وممكن ان
تسافر من هنا الى هناك جميل وقالها بعدها
عبد رب و منصور هادي عندما سقطت عمران
وسقط المعسكر والشهيد القشيبي الله يرحمه
ويرحم كل الشهداء اليمن في النهايه هو دم
يمني يا خالد ماذا قال قال عادت الى حضن
الدوله هل تعتقد ان عبد ربو منصور هادي
الذي يسعى من خلال كل هذه التسريبات ومن
هذه الاعمال الذي يعملها على اساس تحقيق
عقوبات جديده ضد صالح واولاده انه حريص
على دعم الحوثيين واستقبالهم بالاحضان في
حمران ام هو الذي ادخلهم وهو استمرار ل
لمؤامره الاخوان المسلمين في فرز اليمن
وتشتيتها من اجل اعلان الانفصال والدليل
على ذلك اللجان الشعبيه المتواجده في كل
المحافظات الجنوبيه من ابين وتستولي على
المعسكرات واصبحت عدن الان محاصره من ابنه
وحقها جميل جدا طيب كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام اللي نحنا في اخر البرنامج ونريد
ان ناخذ راي الضيفين الان السؤال
المطروح اين يتجه اليمن بعد العوده الى
المربع الاول على صعيد الثوره ماذا تطلب
من اليمنيين الرجل قال قبل قليل صندوق
الاقتراع هو المحك ولا لا والانتخابات
والانتخابات الان يا اخي ذاب الثلج وبان
المرج وعرفتوا مين عدوكم انتم قلتم بعد
الحل اليمني او بعد المبادره الخليجيه لم
تكونوا تعرفون صح ولا لا من هو العدو من
هو الخصم اه الان عرفتموه ماذا ماذا ما
تتوقع هل تعتقد ان اليمن سيذهب في حرب
مذهبيه بين انصار بين بين انصار
الشريعه والحوثيين ماذا بالضبط اولا يا
اخي حميد يدافع عن
نفسه الامر الامر الاخر عبد ربه سيء وانا
قد قلت هذا الكلام من بدري وعلي عبد الله
صالح اسوا مشكلتي مع علي عبد الله صالح
انه
بمثابه غرفه المجاري التي تطلع الاوساخ و
ولذلك اذا اردت ان اعالج المشكله علي ان
اسد هذه الغرفه اولا اسد الغرفه اولا هذه
التي هو هو من ينتج الثعابين وقد قال انه
يرقص على رؤيه الثعابين هذه هذه مشكلتنا
علي عبد الله صالح الان الذي يتنكر اليوم
للسعوديين يتنكر اليوم للسعوديين ويريد
ويقول لايران كان ما قدمتي كشعب ما قدمتي
السعوديه والخليج يعني قدم لي يعني اختلف
مع سياسه السعوديه في اليمن وكانت جزء من
الارباك لكن في الاخير السعوديه وقفت مع
اليمن لكن ايران ماذا قدمت غير القنابل
والاسلحه التي كانت تصدرها للحوثيين
مشكلتنا حقيقه الامر ان العميل مع ايران
هو علي عبد الله صالح والو والحوثي كان
اداته الذي 200
[تصفيق]
مليون الذي باع
علي عبد الله صالح كان عميل
للسعوديه يقول علي عبد الله صالح كانيل
للسعوديه ولا عم ولكن عمته الاان مقبوله
الان الان الحل هو هي حقيقه الثوره لان
علي عبد الله صالح يريد ان يعود بالاموال
التي
نهبها بانتخابات مزوره بدون سجل انتخابي
بظل سيطرته على مؤسسات الدوله علي عبد
الله صالح 19 محافظ محافظه اين الاقصاء
الذي تم فيه بيده كل المعسكرات التي كانت
تتم مشكلتنا فيما يتعلق انه لم تنتزع
السلطه من يد علي عبد الله اشكرك جزيل
الشكر كيف ترد باختصار سلام الله على علي
عبد الله صالح وسلام الله على اليمن
واللعنه على من يريد دمار اليمن اشكرك
جزيل شكر مشاهدينا الكرام لم يبقى لنا ل
نشكر ضيفنا السيد يحيى العابد القيادي في
احزاب التحالف الوطني والسيد خالد الانسي
المحامي والناشط
الحقوقي نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى
ذلك الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيكم العافيه يا جماعه يعطيك
العافيه استاذ يحيى
[موسيقى]
شكرا